do you believe in screenplay structure I
do I believe in the three-act structure
I believe in learning the rules so that
you can then break the rules but there
is an acceptable structure to
storytelling and there's a reason it
works and I think if you can get really
good at that so good that then you can
manipulate it that serves you who was
one of the first books on screenwriting
that you read um I think the Syd field
book because it was required reading for
a USC film school but but it's still a
fantastic book and I think I actually
still have it in my library oh nice okay
when you're writing dialogue ru rules
for it the same or it really depends
because of the character or even the
producer you know what they want it
depends
yeah a lot of it is knowing what the
producer wants but a lot of it also is
just finding the character's voice you
know one of the mistakes a lot of screen
writers make is that they all the all
the characters sound exactly alike you
should be able to you know block out the
character name and know who's talking
and you know you can learn a lot about
how people speak just by sort of
listening like listening in coffee shops
to how people talk and stuff people
rarely are some very self-reflective
people rarely say exactly what they mean
people rarely talk in complete sentences
and so you know the words we choose when
you think about when you go to say
something there's probably a hundred
different ways you could think of to say
it why are you choosing the particular
way you you choose and when you start to
think like that and why your character
is choosing to say something that way
and what they really don't want to
reveal like why ye will they go to this
length but they won't go just a little
bit more vulnerable when you kind of
understand that about your character
then I think writing the dialogue
becomes easier but you have to put that
thought process into it first to know
what they want to conceal and what they
want to to give I think and then and
then you can start working with the
subtext and all that kind of stuff that
makes all of that flavor kind of come
out would you see a lot of the
productions or the networks that you're
writing for are heavy on dialogue just
because I mean the nature of women and
we tend to talk more especially with
other women like it that's we kind of
get together and talk yeah heavy dial I
think well the genres tend to be heavier
on dialogue I think also you know when
you're when you are doing a very
contained like a low budget that has a
lot to do with it too because a lot of
times the people are sitting and talking
right you're in a room you're in a house
or whatever so they're sitting and
talking but I think making sure that
that pacing is good so it just doesn't
feel like really you know people just
explaining things that's kind of the
death of people's dialogue is when
people over explain and they don't know
how to sort of weave in that that
exposition kind of nicely then it really
just kind of like hangs there that's
that's not good writing so hopefully
there's not much of that that you're
watching on television when you're
watching that well just as you said you
know sort of the the tone of the culture
has changed has a tone of conversation
in how you got it change I think it has
I think that people are actually it's
it's less than it used to be because I
think people want things to happen very
quickly you know like the two minute
video versus the seven minute video they
so they want to get through this and the
pacing has to be much more quick than it
used to be so scenes are shorter and so
you get to the point much more quickly I
think that has changed over time
you